ladies and gentlemen
please welcome to the stage
doug stanhope
[Music]
thanks
thanks very much
for public release
on saturday night may 25th
while performing in las vegas
i made comments and performed material
that i now understand to be utterly
deplorable and indefensible
[Applause]
it is now a source of great shame and
embarrassment
and i want to offer my heartfelt
apologies
i'm gutted by my own carelessness and
beg you to know deliver earnestly
this is not who i am
i intend to take
the time in the future for great
soul-searching and hope to come back a
more sensitive and insightful human
being i only wish there was some way i
could go back in time and erase this
whole ugly affair
i like to get ahead of problems
i decide i'm gonna do this whole uh show
backwards kind of where i'm gonna open
with what i was gonna use as my closer
but my closer i really like and it's
about dead kids and that makes me happy
and it sets a tone
for the entire show so i go yeah let's
let's do it that way
perks me up in the beginning
and i'll tell you there used to be
in any given recording or special or
whatever the [ __ ] you call them a large
portion not a large but a certain
percentage of my material
was based on
cable news [ __ ] i watched on cnn or
whatever cable news and i don't have
that anymore because since the election
there's only one [ __ ] subject on
cable news anymore and it's just that
one boring [ __ ] story that i don't
care about i have nothing to add to i
never even say his name on stage just
ignore it
it's your [ __ ] problem you deserve
that [ __ ] guy because you're the
generation that made this happen you are
responsible for making all these
talentless blowhards famous just for
being [ __ ] [ __ ] and now you got
one that you called your leader so [ __ ]
you none of my business i'll be dead
soon
but where it became a deficit to me i
remember right before the election there
was a story about a family at disney
world that was enjoying a vacation and
they were having a nice picnic at the
end of the day on a fake
beach in a fake lake
at disney world or probably a fake
sunset too and
the little toddler boy of the family
wandered out into the drink just a
little bit
and a real alligator
sprung out and ate the boy
which the dad probably thought was fake
too after a whole day at disneyland he
oh there's no surprises for me anymore
real alligator oh [ __ ] that's my voice
so the dad
he grabbed the boy by the wrists but by
now the alligator has the boy up past
the feet past the waist and
as they say in the business
possession is nine tenths of the law
and that has to be a very emasculating
devastating experience where you have to
concede defeat in a tug-of-war with an
alligator when your boy is the rope
i
get that [ __ ]
oh but you try it honey it's a goddamn
alligator
the [ __ ] am i supposed to this whole
vacation was your idea i'm not
responsible for i tried my best
[Music]
and it was like weeks after that story i
remember watching that at two in the
morning and
then the election happens
and then
then that's all they talk about
all the cable news oh did you see what
he tweeted this week that contradicts
what he tweeted last week let's have a
panel of eight eggheads all sit out here
and discuss this for an entire hour
shitty apologize what's your opinion
brian well you know my opinion because
of the network we're on we all have the
same [ __ ] opinion
how many
kids
being eaten by alligator stories am i
missing because of this [ __ ] onion
head in office i have a business to run
people
so now i just get all my news off the
internet so i could
read the headline make sure it's not
about that guy i don't know if i fixate
on dead kids stories because of that
alligator
thing or if maybe i just have a weird
dark
interest in dead kids stories but every
i click on all the dead kids stories
cause they're always
interesting they're always tragic
necessarily
i've never read a
dead kid's story where at the end i felt
justice
you had it coming you prick
how many times did your dad warn you not
to talk on the cell phone in the tub
while it's charging
no they're all tragic but one of the
patterns i've noticed
is almost every dead kid's story
ends with and the family has set up a
gofundme page
for
what i don't know anything about what
it's like to lose a child
but if there's one thing i do know if
nothing else
you're making money
a lot of money
[ __ ] loads of money the literally the
kid the more money you're making
because now
all that money you no longer have to
spend on the the big boy pee pants and
the the lunchables and the juice boxes
that's your petty cash coming right back
into your pockets all the pop warner
gear
and the air jordans and the tuba lessons
that's your [ __ ] money is racing back
into your
fat khaki pockets
the orthodontist the antique that came
straight out at you no longer your
concern that's your bank
it's like you're in one of those phone
booths on a game show where cash blows
all around and you get to snatch as much
out of the air as you possibly can and
you're gonna start a
gofundme page on top of that you greedy
[ __ ]
playing on the sympathies of your
friends and neighbors
you robber baron you rode agents you
you have a little kid that dies you
start a go fund someone else page and
pay it forward
share the wealth
you have a friend that has a little kid
that dies
jack them up for a loan that's the day
day one before everyone else gets to him
sorry as awkward as this seems kevin i
heard you won a lottery of sorts
and uh
i don't know if you heard about the
predicament i'm in i'm in a bit of a
pickle
uh
my kids are
they're still alive
so it's tough times at the jenkins
household
hate to show up with my hand out
the [ __ ] do you need a gofundme for a
dead kid
the only time i've seen it in a story is
where it says to help pay for funeral
costs which is another scam all together
a funeral you just [ __ ]
it's dead it doesn't care
dead things don't give a [ __ ] about all
your
goings on and you're gonna get a
headstone and a coffin for what
you're gonna you're gonna buy a cemetery
plot
for a dead kid
you're gonna buy real estate for a dead
thing while you're still renting
does that make any sense at all
see a little more energy this time huh
[Applause]
you have something that you loved that's
now dead
that vessel is still sitting there
you donate it to science it's what you
do
you [ __ ] spend money on some nonsense
dead things don't care about you
because you
my parents both died and we donated both
of their bodies to science because you
can't chuck it in a dumpster
it's illegal for some reason
you donate it to science and what
happens then is you actually help the
world you donate it to science they show
up they pick up your dead thing they sh
ship it off free of charge to a medical
university where some
hungover
19 year olds are gonna gut open your
aunt betty and start flipping around her
internal organs like it's a benihana and
chase each other around with your mom's
pancreas
quitted
acquitted i'm gonna hurl
still drunk get down
but maybe one of those kids is actually
paying attention and somehow your
donated dead thing will he he finds a
cure for something for some disease or
malady that actually helps society
from your donation rather than you just
being some weird corpse hoarder
and then you did a good thing for the
world that kid's asian by the way
i know they say that there's no
heartache worse than having to bury your
own child and i have to give that to you
i wouldn't know i've never been in that
position
and uh
never put myself at that kind of
disadvantage by having one
but if that is true that that's the
worst heartache that proves my point
that there's a huge difference between a
child and a fetus
because i never had to bury my own child
but
did uh have to pony up for an abortion
when it was my turn to grab the check
and
heartache with an abortion
i could have watched
live footage of that abortion on closed
circuit tv while eating spaghetti
and still gotten distracted and started
checking my tweets
the only heartache you'll ever feel with
an abortion is if you chug the champagne
too quickly afterwards
and if you started a gofundme page for
an abortion
i would kick in a few dollars and
retweet that to my tweeter followers
because that is an effort worth
investing in for the planet
had to get that out
that bit it's important it's dead kids
season memorial day weekend
kicks off dead kids season
you're gonna get back from vegas the
sun's coming out whatever [ __ ] you
live in and you're gonna peel the tarp
off of that above ground pool
you're gonna start pouring the sangrias
a little too
heavy and a little too long
and i didn't think i was that drunk but
you stopped watching the gate and then
all of a sudden little kelsey is now
bobbing around a little blue bobber that
afternoon
right beside the pool noodles and
gonna
fire up the jet ski and
zip sarah around the lake and you didn't
think you were that drunk and now she's
all wrapped up in the propeller
maybe that asian student that was paying
attention could figure out nerve
propellers if you donate her to science
i don't know where you guys are from and
i don't give a [ __ ] but
wherever you're going back to i'm sure
i'm booked there
eventually whatever
horrible it's so weird to to be
filming this at the plaza because i have
been coming here
by choice
since before i even did comedy this is
my this is my place this is my old
school vegas
place
and [ __ ]
oscars
steakhouse and
even the worst parts of it i have to go
i
that's the reason i come here it's
vintage [ __ ] vegas
i don't get to
normally play any place that i want to
be
or you want to be at the same time
i usually have to play where you live
and you're stuck
and then i'm stuck there with you
playing in some [ __ ] mall
in a s
some hideous
city
i just i i had to i ate at an outback
steakhouse last week
in a [ __ ] mall
and there was people there like are you
a comic too cause
unless you're stuck and that's the only
thing walking distance why would you be
in here
outback steakhouse couldn't be less
authentic if jim jeffries was your
waiter
sorry jim
i had to do it
but that's what i do for a living i come
visit you in [ __ ] horrible places and
then i'm stuck there for at least a day
usually at a an airport hotels a
mid-range like 2.5 star
beige-ish brownish
salmon colored
in it's always an in like a days inn or
a comfort inn or a quality inn and
they're all in a [ __ ] row
and
you walk in and it's full of mid-range
2.5 star folks doing
dumb [ __ ] oh it's a dance moms
competition this weekend and there's a
bunch of kids and ballerina outfits and
[ __ ]
i'm using my roller bag as a cane
coming in shit-faced and there's kids
pressing every button on the elevator
because their parents can't afford six
flags so this is a thrill ride for the
kid to go up and down and you go don't
hit the kid don't hit the kid it's not
your kid if if you had your own kid you
could beat your kid in effigy of that
kid but it's not your kid so don't hit
the kid
talk to the businessman
with the [ __ ] lanyard there's an old
conventioneer business [ __ ] you look
like mitch mcconnell and you have really
bad small talk but a very large lanyard
they wear big lanyards around there
northeast arkansas assembly of special
needs educators
yeah
well you need a [ __ ] backstage pass
that size to get into that 8 30 a.m ted
talk are you kidding
i stole a croissant off your table in
front of that [ __ ] banquet room and i
didn't need a pass i just stole the
[ __ ] thing i think you're so
important
you wake up in the morning and you're
fighting old people for some humid lobby
waffle in the morning
before they shut it down
and then i go to the show after a day of
reading
tweets from you [ __ ] animals
pre-gaming for the doug stanhope show
tonight in des moines and it's a picture
of you drinking wild turkey at 10 in the
morning oh you're gonna be a treasure to
deal with at [ __ ] 9 30 at night
and then it's just a fist fight shut the
[ __ ] up yelling at you and i get back to
my beige brown salmon colored
hotel and the final insult as you get to
your room and your key card
[ __ ] you [ __ ] red light red
light red light you [ __ ] red red red
green light oh no god damn it
and then i stomp back like a giant baby
down to the front desk you [ __ ]
and i just explode all of this [ __ ] all
over some night auditor my key card
doesn't work again
big [ __ ] screaming baby
i'm sorry sir did did you have it near
your cell phone or your credit card at
any point
probably
yeah everyone's got cell phones and
credit cards everywhere and what do you
mean by near my cell phone or credit
card if it's here is that near that and
what's the radius and you know what my
cell phone and my
credit cards still work so what the [ __ ]
is wrong with your key card
sir if you just calm down i'm i'm trying
to help you
what's your name and your room number
stanhope
217.
clack clack crack crack crack crack
sir i'm sorry
there's no one by that name
in this hotel
look at the key card your [ __ ]
hampton in it's next door you all look
the same
[ __ ] you i am not apologizing you all
looked a goddamn same
[Applause]
i prefer a one-star hotel
i really do i'm more comfortable a
one-star motel the old-school
motor lodge you know the like route 66
[ __ ] the u-shaped
one story you just bag has got a pool in
the middle of the driveway that's no
longer a pool it's full of cement and
some old police tape around it and you
just back your van this close to the
motel room door and you just hurl your
[ __ ] inside you don't have to interact
with people just leave me the buck alone
i look for my lodging based on the one
star review
because a one star review will tell you
things that you're secretly looking for
that the proprietor could not openly
promote
one star i didn't get a wink sleep in
this place because it's attached to a
dive bar that's open until four o'clock
in the morning
complete purchase now
[Applause]
this is no place for children no place
is a place for children except maybe a
you know a cat carrier and a storage
unit that'd be fine
i think they were running prostitutes
out of the room next door
one star the entire place reeked of
stale cigarette smoke
oddly that's my cologne i wear it daily
and if it already stinks like that i
don't have to worry about that [ __ ]
250 dollar cleaning fee if you smoke in
the room initial here oh don't worry
lady i will be smoking in that room
but i'll it'll be fine because when i
get home from that [ __ ] ugly show i'm
gonna put a wet towel under the door i'm
gonna chain smoke cigarettes while i
ignore
missed calls from friends that i don't
keep in touch with anymore and [ __ ]
regret my life and uh in the morning i'm
going to check out a bit early and what
i'm going to do is i'm going to stuff a
giant rotted catfish
into your microwave unit and i'm going
to set that for about 45 minutes
i'm gonna shuffle off to breakfast
and while that beast of burden slowly
explodes and blisters and
bleeds and burns onto the walls of that
microwave unit i'll be dining
comfortably in the knowledge that you're
never gonna be able to smell cigarettes
in that room again
we'll all be just fine
and before you ask well where do you get
a giant
dead rotted catfish
every night on the road
it's in my rider
i don't ask for a lot
i'll eat the green m m's
i just want some plastic jug vodka some
muddy bears and a giant
dead catfish and or carp cause i'm not
picky i'm not a brand [ __ ]
except for the muddy bears
gay cousin eric came on the road with us
once
and uh
hey
gay cousin eric you get a fan out there
somewhere
he is turning 21 and he thought it would
be exciting to do a tour for a week on
the road with us because he had some i
don't know what you even imagined the
road is like but it's not that like if
you have like high
no
but gay cousin eric is 21 and he thought
it's all gonna be like you know
strippers and after parties and [ __ ]
penthouse suites and plates of blow in
the green room and eric we don't even
have a green room half the time when
we're playing the middle of this pig
country a lot of times we're just
sitting in the van at the fire exit in
the back alley of some [ __ ]
gin joint road house place
staring at our shoes that's what we do
on the road we stare at our [ __ ]
shoes yell at people get back in the van
after about three days of dead silence
no one talks in the van you wake up you
get in stare at your shoes greg chaley
will put on a podcast of a comedian that
you hate so you can silently judge him
as you sweat out alcoholic remorse
and gay cousin eric's all happy oh we're
going to chicago can we go to wrigley
field do you think that we could uh go
to the blues hall of fame i go no we
don't we don't do
things
and i remember that chicago gig we were
staying on the outer loop of chicago in
one of these jalopy motels and it's like
5 30 at night still no one's talking
we're eating some gas station pizza
nothing we're not hungry
it's just at that hour you have to throw
some kind of wet doughy substance down
your neck
just to slow up the flow of the alcohol
that's about to be dumped your way at
show time as a prophylactic measure this
is it's
it's the same way you would sandbag
before a flood
it's not aesthetics it's for safety
so we're jamming pizza in our head
quietly
and gay cousin eric
it was one of those moments where i just
saw the exact moment where all his hopes
and ambitions for this fun on this tour
just dropped out of his face like his
face
fell you know when like you do
hallucinogens with a a buddy and you can
have an entire dialogue with just one
glance just one look on your face you've
spoken volumes you're just like
and you know every single thing that
you're but this was the opposite with
eric because it was a negative where i
just saw him look up at me like
just it was that subtle but i know what
he meant
and uh it's not gonna get better eric
keep in mind eric gay cousin eric was
not my cousin he he's at that time he
was my brother's
my brother's then wife's
now ex-wife but her her nephew not even
close to related he's not even really
gay we we called him gay cousin eric to
hide the fact that he was jewish that
was the running joke
so i'm not really invested in how much
of a good time eric is or is not having
but at that moment he had pizza sauce on
his face and he just reached down and
grabbed a hand towel off the carpet and
my reflexes were not quick enough to
stop this from happening so in slow
motion i'm going
oh
no
[Music]
whoa
[Music]
no eric now
eric you you never use the face cloth
that's underneath the laptop
in a comedian's motel room
oh
oh you're gay now cousin eric
oh you're so gay
now i bet there's a one-star review
about that motel from gay cousin eric
now
the linens were really crusty
exfoliating but ugh
i would guess at this point probably
three quarters of the email i get are
survey
spam basically like everything you buy
every [ __ ] service you get somehow
they have my email address and they want
to know hey how about some feedback
your oil changed to give us some
feedback the cable guy came to your
house and how was your experience and
[ __ ] every amazon purchase you make
right
take a few minutes and write a review
why buy way too much [ __ ] from amazon to
right take a few minutes every [ __ ]
purchase like cocktail straws here these
plastic cocktail straws because they're
disappearing so i'm stockpiling them
they're replacing them
with [ __ ] bamboo paper [ __ ]
no i'm not putting i'm not gonna
disrespect a cocktail with some [ __ ]
paper straw that's just gonna flatten
out
[Music]
so i buy these like a dollar ninety-nine
for a thousand from china with no
shipping charge i don't know how that's
humanly possible to send me a thousand
but then you get
repeated
[ __ ] amazon spam hey tell us about
your purchase share with our customers
your review of [ __ ] plastic cocktail
straws really how could i really make
that interesting i'm gonna take it and
when you don't they go you must have
forgot
i didn't forget i said [ __ ] you no
not a i'm not a cocktail straw reviewer
how desperate is everybody for some
review pat on the back star
it's like if you were getting your dick
sucked
i'm getting my [ __ ] sucked and every
stroke they stop oh oh
is that okay
is that right
[Music]
if there's anything you want me to do
different tell me i'm open to
suggestions
would you recommend it to a friend
on a scale from one to five five being
the best very satisfied somewhat
satisfied dissatisfied
[Music]
and i'm just laying back there going sir
if i didn't like it i would have shown
you to the door just [ __ ] man up and
finish the job
if i have some beef
with a big corporation i'm not going to
waste that grievance in an email i am
going to call the 800 number old school
because i want the human connection
where i can hear the tears on the other
end of the phone
when i bellow at them
because i wake up hating myself and want
to blame the rest of the world and i use
that as an outlet and i don't
target
indian call centers
it's just they're the ones invariably
who answer the phone anymore when you're
angry at a corporation
and you want to give them [ __ ] they
transfer all the [ __ ] calls to some poor
[ __ ] india and i don't want to rain
on their already dreary parade
but even when i try not to they [ __ ] it
up just in the
greeting
when she says thank you for calling
directv
my name is
madison how may i help you no no it's
not
your name's not madison
nobody in mumbai india is named madison
i haven't even opened my mouth and
you've already lied to me
on the phone
tell me your real [ __ ] name i am a
long-term goddamn customer i have 19
direct tv boxes so i can get every game
at my house because i have to buy my
friends and i deserve more respect than
for you to open a phone call lying to my
[ __ ] face tell me your real goddamn
name
just on that i don't even remember the
reason i called to begin with now it's
just give me your [ __ ] real name on
principle
and i just and when the anger tactic
doesn't get the results i'm looking for
then i come in soft good cop bad cop
hey maddie
listen
i know the game
i understand the racket you live in a
poor country it's hard to feed your
family yeah you had to take this [ __ ]
job at a call center to make ends meet
your own name is unpronounceable in the
english language they made you pick a
stripper name out of a training manual
i get it you picked madison there's
nothing wrong with that but maddie i'm
not a customer right now
right now i'm your friend
we're two human beings sharing one
honest moment on a telephone line so be
my friend and be honest with me
what's your real name
my
my name is
madison you're a [ __ ] lying pig
how [ __ ] dare you
i know where you live
i'm a goddamn american i'll have your
village bombed
send in the drones
the call invariably ends with i hope you
get gang-raped
no because i want her to know that i
have some insight into her culture
because that's how they do
in the india that's a thing
it's what they have to deal with
indian men gang rape it's
sad and it's savage and
because indian men
are not
strong enough
to rape
by themselves it's
it's physiology or
sociology it's
it's [ __ ] science you get your ged
and come debate me but it's it's true
indian men don't have the upper body
strength
to pin and submit
do you ever see a indian dude in the ufc
no
you never will
unless he's a ring girl
that's why they created their god vishnu
with so many arms
to represent
what it would take
for even their god
to be able to take a lady down
alone
i don't
don't take this the wrong way i'm saying
indian men
are basically
the women
of men
in that they
like if there were no women indian men
would be the ones that you'd want to
make the love at
hopefully
like on a good day yeah sometimes you're
going to get drunk and slum it with a
hipster but
you're going to be imagining him as an
indian man underneath you because
because indian men are the most
beautiful
polite
accommodating
docile supple of men they have that sick
silky thick black hair just dense
everywhere their whole head
their whole one eyebrow their back
soles of their feet legend has it
hair as thick as their head like a
slipper on the bottom of their feet
skating on sunshine
indian men are the most attractive of
men
not to women
hence the rape problem
with their gang raping
but
[Applause]
but i am a i'm a dreamer i'm an idealist
i
i like to believe in a world where
everyone lives on a level playing field
where everybody's equal where an indian
man could at least
believe in himself enough and have the
courage to
at least try
to rape solo
he couldn't do it like
a panic
indian guy tried to rape you all by
himself in a dark parking lot
[Music]
you would just laugh like you're
laughing now
and put your hand on his forehead
like when your four-year-old nephew
tries to swing punches at you and you
just hold him out of arm's reach until
he tuckers himself out he gets all tired
and then you laugh and you go back to
easter dinner and everyone has a fine
time
but at least that guy had enough
self-esteem
to make the attempt
a community lifted him up enough
to have this self-confidence
to try because nobody ever wants to die
thinking what if
at least he put it out there
and i'll be honest
i don't know
if
this bit
has a point
but if there is a point
it's this
is it wrong to use racism to try to stop
gang
rape and that's a question for you to
answer
individually
[Music]
[Applause]
don't shoot the messenger i put that on
you and you have to make the decision
which is right and which is wrong and
either answer you come up with
you're a [ __ ] [ __ ]
you're either a vulgar racist or you're
a gang rape apologist
either way you're sick in me
i can't believe i performed for you
people
[Applause]
hey this got full
[Applause]
on the night of saturday may 25th i made
wildly inappropriate stereotypes
regarding indian men that i thought were
set in confidence
i hadn't noticed the cameras the
microphone and the giant shrieking
audience
yet still this does not excuse
me promoting such a myopic denigration
of a country wonderfully rich in
heritage and humanity
i hope this apology will usher in a new
era
of understanding and open a dialogue
that allows
all of us to grow
[Applause]
and rape jokes are never funny
you cannot make jokes about rape because
at least the rape culture and rape jokes
are never funny
that's the thing if you're a new comic
in here and you're dealing with all that
[ __ ] [ __ ]
just just ride it out it's always gonna
be something i've been doing this since
1990 and there's always a topic that
everyone decides now you can't when i
started in vegas in 1990 at the dive bar
thank you
yeah that back to 1990 when i started
open mics it was aids jokes oh my god if
you ever mentioned aids on stage no
there's no
funny thing it's just awful and how dare
you you're contemptible
and then a decade later
9 11 jokes you cannot mention 911 unless
you're doing some bogus uh let's take a
moment and a pause for the first
responders because it's a difficult time
we're going through
yeah it was that then look at those two
subjects now [ __ ] hilarious
write it out
if you bundled all three of those topics
and you had the premise of like uh rogue
aids on airplanes flying into the twin
towers without their consent
like
just the premise gets a laugh without
even a
punchline let it go it's always gonna be
something and someone's gonna always be
[ __ ] upset and
i feel honestly i feel like i lost a lot
of street cred with my people
for not being outed in the whole metoo
movement i
i think a lot of people were expecting
that and let down when it never happened
and i it's not like i don't have my
stories
i
i've yeah i had me tooted up
yeah
that was me first i tried to start that
hashtag when i was doing it about me
i mean first
for the record i was never in the uh
you know the the rape happy deep end of
that
ugly part of the metoo swimming pool
with harvey weinstein but in the shallow
end and the kiddie pool part that
pull your dick out in front of people
how many people haven't seen my dick at
this point
half my career that would be a go-to
thing if i couldn't remember my next bit
on stage i just pulled my dick out
hey take a polaroid picture with the
jagermeister girls and five dollars yeah
i'm pulling my dick out i pulled my dick
out all the time i pulled my dick out in
front of louis ck and there's a picture
of it in my book
i credit the predators
and unlike louis ck i didn't ask him
permission politely first
just pulled my dick up for a picture
i can't get me too i had a friend of
mine a comedian named alicia wood that
tried to me to me last year on twitter
with a story that only
made me think
oh [ __ ]
that story should be in my act
i forgot all about it she just reminded
me of a hilarious story that i
banked away somewhere in some dead gray
synapse
then i called her up and i go
what the [ __ ] are you doing
like that story needs to be written long
form you can't there's so much meat to
that story now that i'm remembering it
you can't put that in a tweet so i'm
helping you write and edit
my own me too me story
because it's [ __ ] funny and she's
wasting it
the story is
early 2000s probably we're playing a
comedy club looney's in colorado springs
and uh
after the show
some guys wanted a picture with me and
back then again pulling my dick out was
a regular thing for me
back then that was
cd days where you'd have a cd you sold
after a show for five bucks for gas
money and i didn't people would say hey
will you sign it and i i go oh i don't
have a catch phrase like get her done or
nanu nanu or something so i just
occasionally pull my dick out and trace
my shrunken dick on the ins insert and
then sign over it because i had plenty
of room for both
and
that was it was a different day and age
it's not like the current climate which
i hate that
the current climate you know what when
you never leave your house
the current climate is wherever you set
the thermostat
when you left last
so these guys they want a picture and i
go okay
let's all drop trout for the picture ha
stand in the lobby of a comedy club with
her dicks out
dude it was funny
the guy next to me we called him fester
afterwards because he looked like uncle
fester he's a kid a little bald-headed
fire plug of a dude he pulled his pants
down
and he had micro penis which is what
it's called the medical condition like
real micro penis not oh looks like it's
cold out
no he had like a half a thumbnail
like a carbuncle he had like just
no dick
but he pulled his pants down with such
heroics and aplomb and
careless reckless abandon that's what it
is
reckless abandon
pause for edit cause that's what i
wanted to say all weekend
he pulled his pants down with such
reckless abandon
to show off the smallest penis in the
world that we immediately fell in love
with this guy like you
are the [ __ ] gutsiest beautiful
[ __ ] strong human being we befriended
him and we took him out with us and we
brought him to all the bars and got him
hammered and then he ends up back at the
comedy condo which is you know
a apartment where they put up three
comics three bedrooms and we got more
drunk there and at some point it was my
idea
to do
blindfold hand job
and i said fester this is what
what we're going to do is we're going to
blindfold you as me and my buddy ben
and a waitress that was a drunkard and a
player and a [ __ ]
regular
solid folk and uh
i said we're gonna blindfold you
and you have to guess which one of the
three of us
is giving you a hand job
and i know she's gonna do it we made the
eye contact she's in
but even if she
bailed out i would have done it because
his penis was so small as to be
non-threatening
to a level where you would touch it
anyway as a curiosity
so i blindfold fester with my
bathrobe tie
and she unzips his pants and ben and i
hide around the corner a little bit
because we don't want to laugh and give
away who's giving him a hand job but she
gives it away right away cause she
starts giving him the best
dirty talk you porn hand job
she's like oh i can't wait to see this
[ __ ] come for me it's [ __ ] beautiful
oh god
this is so hot i want to see your [ __ ]
drip all over my
and ben and i are both
leaning in with half boners
wishing we had micro penis
because this is the best hand job ever
and the only thing i noticed that was
missing was she needed a lube so i
tiptoe across the carpet of the living
room get to the kitchen and i grabbed
some palm olive dish soap
which
not a sponsor yet
but when this story comes out i'm sure
will be flooded with money i i
rain palm oil of all over this little
dick hand job
and then i get a little carried away
and i thought what other condiments can
i
put into this he's blindfolded so i
opened the refrigerator and then mustard
is too cruel i found crumbled goat
cheese
and i sprinkle a good amount of that
into the hand job
and then i run back over with ben still
trying not to laugh and ruin his
experience
and the part that i hadn't remembered
was alicia wood
she was there
she was the opening act
sleeping like a baby in the third
bedroom so evidently i went and i woke
her up you got to get up
you're missing it
just get out here
but [ __ ] what all you want will you just
come down the hole watch
what i it's micro penis goat cheese dish
so bad
what
this my carpet is dish soap gucci's just
come here look
look
oh [ __ ] what the [ __ ] is sad it's like
tiny tickets
she's like just [ __ ] off and
she went back to bed and then [ __ ] 18
years later
tried to me too that story in a tweet
and said it made her feel uncomfortable
what
it's a [ __ ] hilarious thing
like if i was a new comic
on the road and i got taken out i'm
actually doing this as a professional
now and i get to be in a comedy condo
and uh all the other comics are
witnessing
goat cheese micropenis dish soap and job
and you didn't wake me up for that
i would take that as a strong signal
that i'm not welcome
in the group
why would you [ __ ] leave me out like
some rudolph the red-nosed reindeer wake
me up
you're uncomfortable
imagine a kid's mom having to do his
laundry
the next day she's uncomfortable what
are you you're uncomfortable what are
you [ __ ] lactose intolerant and now
goat cheese is a trigger
for your
you don't like sudsy hand jobs with your
choice of toppings what the [ __ ]
fester had a better me too story in that
than she did she just looked around a
corner that kid was coerced by a
a powerful man that he respected and
looked up to and
was coerced into receiving a hand job he
may or may not have wanted
i think there's a lot of crossover in
the metoo movement where a lot of the
people that you are trying to
out and shame and say [ __ ] off there's a
good cross section are
the same people that i am afraid of the
[ __ ]
douchebag saturday night last call
[ __ ] [ __ ] jocko bro dudes when
they can't [ __ ] you they want to fight
me that you're hey lady nice tits i get
what are you looking at [ __ ] it's the
same guys
there's a big
cross-section of that
yet i'm still expected to fight that guy
he calls you [ __ ] why don't you just
punch him in the face hey he said you
had nice tits why didn't you just suck
his dick
that's what he wants i don't want to
fight him and you don't want to suck
your stick
but it's the same douchebag
but i don't get to ride your hashtag
[ __ ] weak dude gets nothing we'll
learn to fight
let's just learn to suck dick
[ __ ] learn to fight i can't fight
would you call me
stupid
rape is not a crime of sex it's a crime
of violence you know what so is violence
a crime of violence where's my [ __ ]
hashtag protection
i walk into a bar i get my head stoved
in because i walk into a raiders bar
wearing a broncos jersey and everyone
says i was asking for it by the way i
was dressed
just saying equal protection
[Applause]
i don't even go out i i only go out like
after shows when it's with you where i
go oh i got
i got people here i don't go out
people scare the [ __ ] out of me they're
awful
we were in uh we were in indianapolis
we're going through a car wash because
that's one of the fun things you can do
as a tourist in indiana
just go through a car wash when it's not
even your car it was a [ __ ] rental
car you're washing other people's [ __ ]
because it's the worst state of the 50
and
and we get into the car wash it's just
me and greg chaley my tour manager and
uh it's a huge line that we get stuck in
but i needed a haircut so i spot a
barber shop across the strip mall
parking lot i bet greg chaley 20 bucks
that i could get my hair cut before he
can get through this interminable line
in a car wash because that's another fun
thing you could do as a tourist in
indiana it's just been 20 on any stupid
thing
and hopefully the wager makes it
exciting
how many plates do you think that fat
[ __ ] gonna eat at the golden corral
i'll give you over under five and a half
not counting the chocolate waterfall
because he'll probably just stick his
tongue in there and not even use a plate
on his way out
so i race as fast as old fat smoker can
race across the parking lot to the
barber shop [ __ ] you jaylee i'll beat
you this time
and i get
to the barber shop door and i whip it
open
and
oh
oh it's really crowded
and it's a barber shop
like those movies
it's a very urban audience
it's
ethnic crowd
the defensive line in football
your atlanta-based flight crew
the new zealand rugby team
however you say the all blacks
there's a [ __ ] sea of black dudes
staring right back at me
and i held this position for far too
long
it's frozen
i don't know what my play is at this
point they don't seem to want me here
i still don't know what i should have
done at that point but i know what i did
i kind of ran
i think a little bit i acted like i
opened the wrong business door in the
strip mall i'm looking for something
else oh i'm sorry
i was looking for the bridal shop next
door i'm getting married in the morning
thanks for having me sorry wrong my bad
because my first thought was
there's no way i'm gonna win the bet
with chaley now because those places
mobbed every stool is full there's 11
other guys on the back wall waiting in
line i can't win my second thought which
is my first thought and every other
thought i had
i'm terrified
by a room full of black dudes staring
hard at me
because i've been a human being for over
a half a century and one thing i've
noticed about the human condition is
most people are ugly angry [ __ ] scary
animals
if you're confronted with a group of any
type of the same types of human being
and you're the one guy different maybe a
good time to
kind of run
if i opened that door and it was a room
full of hells angels or snake handling
evangelicals
i wouldn't have stopped and gone
oh wait they're all white they'll love
me
no you get the [ __ ] out of there
if it was a room full of indian men
cup your [ __ ]
and run anywhere but to public transit
because that's where they get you
according to the news reports
so i get about halfway across the
parking lot and this old barber comes
out and he looks like morgan freeman and
he's smiling with every tooth in his
mouth i could see from a distance
because he he's so happy he saw right
through my [ __ ] he knows exactly
what was going through my mind
and he was
hey man
where are you going
oh they're gonna [ __ ] with me
i see where this is going
and i i i wander back over and i mumble
some excuse about my friends in the car
wash and i know there's a lot of people
in line and i can't i don't have time to
wait and he goes oh no there's no wait
i'll take you right now
[Laughter]
and he walks me back in like i'm a child
that just got caught running away from
summer camp
and i get in and there was no weight
because all those guys on the back wall
they're just hanging out in a [ __ ]
barber shop they're not there to get
their haircut this is [ __ ] watching
tv and [ __ ] that's what they do i
thought that was an urban
myth all pun intended but no they
actually just [ __ ] hang out like it's
a bar
and i walk in and at this point i am
visibly trembling
because i'm sober
it's early in the day i want to explain
that to everybody in there
oh this has nothing to do with the color
of your skin i'm a long-term alcoholic
this this is what 2 30 in the afternoon
looks like every day of my life you
don't get credit for the booze shakes
that's mine
don't explain anything just shut up and
sit down and get your hair cut be polite
and he sits me in the barber stool and
spins me to the mirror
and around the mirror just like your
mom's beauty parlor they have
photographs of all the different
hairstyles
that are available to me today
and i can't find any that are
appropriate for my head
they're gonna carve a dollar bill symbol
into the side of my skull and i'm just
gonna sit here and take it
they're gonna put an la clippers logo on
the
back of my balden paint and i'm just
gonna smile and say
thanks shut up
get your hair cut
be polite
over tip
which in that environment means tip
whatsoever
and get the [ __ ] out
and it was the best haircut experience
i've ever had in my life it's a [ __ ]
old dude like me a lot of times i've
noticed i was suited up thankfully and
when you're wearing a [ __ ]
over-the-top grotesquely loud suit and
you have your [ __ ] together a black guy
will [ __ ] notice that that [ __ ]
yes when your socks match your tie
brother man that's [ __ ] sharp and he
did it he's old guy so he did all my old
crazy eyebrows and my ear hairs and he
hot toweled me
i i begged off when i was offered the
straight razor shave
only because he's an old dude like me
and i don't know how much he drinks
every night and i don't know how stable
his hands are so i i walked at that
point
but uh would i go back [ __ ] no
not unless they move out of indiana is
the worst [ __ ] state no i should
never have to play there again i'd
rather have [ __ ] ear hair than have
to play indiana again
it's their turn to [ __ ] move
i like to stop right now and uh point
out
i am not
racist and i only say that not because i
give a [ __ ] if you're offended
i say that because i worry that
a lot of you might be racist
and i need you to know i'm not your
friend
if you can't read context into these
bits or tone
or intent it's not my fault
they say that you know what
jokes uh have circumstances words hurt
you might think that they're just jokes
but
it's how other people interpret them and
if they interpret them wrong well if
they interpret them wrong then [ __ ]
yell at them give me [ __ ]
don't just because you guys don't get it
and you [ __ ] up my comedy
yell at them them too
hashtag them too
stupid idiots that don't get it
[Applause]
i am not
i am not racist but that doesn't mean
there's other people i don't hate for
just as stupid a reason
just race isn't one of them i have my
own isms sometimes there's types of
people that just [ __ ] you off
and it's just as dumb as any other
but you can't help it
it's an internal hate you just shut the
[ __ ] up and be polite i'm i am an ageist
that is my big ism
i am
disgusted by graphically elderly people
they gross me out so much i can't be
around them i don't know why you bring
them out in public
i'm talking like like gross elderly like
not not cute keith richards is still
alive or betty white or something
functional elderly i'm talking about the
gross things that you bring out of a
home like kirk douglas kind of grows
and you bring them into public i'm just
trying to eat brunch at a perkins on a
sunday morning
with a hangover and then i see the van
pull up and you're bringing out your
[ __ ] old thing
can folk under each chicken wing one
more step berthenia here you go there
you go there you go
there you go your other foot good
the tongue is darting in and out of
their mouth
it's called tardive dyskinesia where
they can no longer control their mouth
and the tongue just
it darts in and out like whack-a-mole
it's all coated like they've been
licking cheese or
chalk a rec room somewhere where their
family abandoned them
oh
oh you're almost to the door birthday
you're doing so good there we go and you
know they're gonna sit that [ __ ]
thing next to me i guarantee it their
skin is all dried and
blanched like rice paper with big purple
splotches underneath it you know if you
accidentally drug an angry hangnail
across that it would bleed sausage
here we go we're almost to the table
[Music]
yeah it's [ __ ] right next to me
their eyes don't work anymore but the
pockets underneath the big
pink
pockets
are full of fluid
to the like an infinity pool they're
full to the
top you know if you stuck one finger in
the lower lid
all that liquid would just pour down
their face like ocular [ __ ]
yeah
it's sitting next to me
they got scabs that were never a cut
there used to be a sunspot and now it's
some thick pepperoni
dried and curling up off their scalp
and i'm trying to eat undercooked eggs
benedict right next to this
god offer [ __ ] sake i'll take it to go
yeah it's a horrible [ __ ] way to feel
about
people but it's honest you don't say it
i think ageism is the worst ism to have
when you're aware of it like
being an ageist on that level is like if
you were a racist who's very aware that
you're rapidly turning black yourself
and somehow you still can't quell the
hate
uh
uh ridiculing old [ __ ] who are unable
to defend themselves is punching down
and certainly something i would never do
i was taken out of context i was on
ambien
russians hacked my teleprompter
that's just not
funny it's out of context with all of my
standards and morals there's some issues
that you just never make fun
you shouldn't make fun
i look
[Applause]
just the idea that the expression making
fun could ever be a negative
you shouldn't make fun what
i'm sorry did i take some subjects that
are ugly and dark and soul
lacerating
painful
shitty
maybe unavoidable in life kind of stuff
and i made it
fun
what a dick i must be
i can't believe just for attempting that
herculean feat of making awful [ __ ] fun
this is what you have to do
in life
is try to make fun if you if you know
how life works
it starts out where you're born into
being fed a hard diet of lies and
fantasies and fabrications and then that
just turns into a series of
disappointments as you start to figure
out everything you know is wrong and
then you get to live in the failures one
after another and tragedies that are
just waiting in the bushes to jump out
and bite you in the [ __ ] thigh
and then at best it ends with you on a
cold slab in a medical university
with hungover teenagers throwing around
your internal organs waving your [ __ ]
dead wang at each other and laughing and
that's the best that can happen so in
the meantime
you better try to make that [ __ ] fun
we had a friend
and a fan that died laura kimball was
her name and she was the best
version of the word fan and
and i'm dedicating this
special to her because if there's one
thing that she loved more than comedy it
was empty gestures
so i'm gonna dedicate this to her
she had a perfect life she is 42
husband making bank in silicon valley
she's beautiful with two beautiful
little toe-headed bart and lisa simpson
kind of kids
gated community all the [ __ ] so she
could come out to all of our shows
anytime we're up and down the west coast
she sat in the laura kimble chair
that side of front row and uh she called
me up she said i just got diagnosed with
stage four melanoma it spread to my
brain
and they're giving me six months to live
on the outside and i don't know what to
do
and i said oh i'm playing san jose in a
month
so
try to hang out that long
and then we'll come goof around well i'm
not a [ __ ] doctor i'm not gonna give
her what other advice am i gonna give
her a new [ __ ] easter treatment
no
she's killing i'll be there don't die
till i get to san jose and she showed up
in the chair she looked really good i
had written a whole pocket full of ha ha
you're gonna die a brain cancer type of
jokes just to [ __ ] with her and roast
her a little bit because that's what
she'd want that's what she would expect
and uh we had a great night and two
months later i'm playing santa cruz just
down
the street basically and there she is
again with no warning and she looked a
little worse for the wear but still
pretty good
but
now
i'm out of haha you're going to die a
brain cancer joke so i had no
preparation so i'm trying to riff off
the top of my head haha laura has a
brain cancer
until i go back into my same old boring
act that she's heard over and over
this continues
for months she lived 13 months and every
few months
she'd just show up at my show hearing
the same [ __ ] act at one point i
leaned into her and i go laura would you
please [ __ ] die
you're ruining my comedy
it's so hard to [ __ ] say the same
material but you're sitting there and
you i know you've heard it
and that night i said to her i said how
am i gonna know
when you're dead cause we don't have any
mutual friends i just know you from all
these shows from the years
and you can't tweet me from hell
which is where you're going
but she said i gave my husband paul your
number take down his number he's gonna
call you when the inevitable happens so
i put paul kimball into my phone under
warning warning major buzz kill do not
answer bad news only
i know what the [ __ ] i'm gonna say to
this guy
so when i got the call from her husband
i decided i'm just gonna talk to him the
same way you talk to any one of your
drinking buddies who just got dumped by
some short-term tinder skank or
something
and i just talked to him i go hey hey
what's up
how's it going
oh
oh she's dead
yeah [ __ ] her anyway dude
[ __ ] her you don't need that [ __ ]
you could do way better than her what
are you kidding
[ __ ] be a [ __ ] about this let's get
back out there come on nobody even liked
her
i'm gonna cry about this let's go to
vegas and hit some titty bars and bang
some 12 ounce curls and we're gonna
change your facebook status to player
be a [ __ ] whining [ __ ] about this
and he laughed
which was a pretty big gamble
it's a pretty big roll of the dice to
take that tact
but that's what you have to do when life
gets its ugliest it's your
responsibility to dig into the muck and
try to make
fun and if they don't laugh you just cut
them out of your social circle
it's that simple
get rid of them
life is too short to hang around with
people who don't get the goof
[ __ ] them
thank you very much
i appreciate you coming out
i'll be out there in the casino at some
point
before you
before you talk to me or ask me for a
picture if i'm gambling see the look on
my face to see if i'm losing or not
good night
[Applause]
you